dang i really burnt this like the pan is
black at the bottom what's up y'all it's
michael and today i'm gonna be cooking
three palestinian meals for my mom or if
i come into the kitchen and try to give
a suggestion or anything she's like
you need to leave even though i am a
professional palestinian by nature of
being palestinian i am not a
professional
cook but i have help so today i'm gonna
be using the satan book
and this is an icon a staple
we're gonna see how it goes all right
can we bring in the talent
come here come here i'm back so this is
my mom
so i will get back in touch with you we
will circle back
when i'm ready for the taste testing so
the first dish that i'm gonna make
is the aleia bandura sauteed tomato with
lemon and garlic i decided that i want
to go for something simple at first
because
i don't want to get too complicated from
the beginning so i have my tomatoes
fresh off the vine from the grocery
store
i'm just gonna slice them thick
according to my mother
thick oh yeah dang that is a thick
tomato
that is a thick slice i hear my mom
coming
okay got my garlic garlic garlic
garlic we love garlic in this household
i'm just going to use my pestle and
mortar
it's a lot of work hold on
my garlic is ground okay and then she
said
some olive oil so unfortunately we ran
out of our olive oil from the holy land
but
you know arabs love costco so we have
our kirkland brand olive oil
oh that's a lot of olive oil actually
this is what i'm gonna do but this is
what my mom does she like puts her hand
out
she squeezes that way if you get any
seeds
they won't go into your thing i don't
think my mom really likes pepper so i
won't do too much
but also it's not about her just kidding
it is
okay so here's our olive oil mixture
all right so now it's time to cook it
actually
i'm struggling hold on
i am eating elayed vadora sorry if i
look stiff i just don't eat on camera
really nice simple dish it's great for
vegetarians it's great for lent
it looks pretty actually it looks really
nice maybe a little too much oil than i
would prefer
smells good you can smell the garlic in
it which i love because i use garlic in
everything
garlic it's nice and soft maybe it
should have been cooked down a little
bit more
but i'm okay with that
next time maybe a little more garlic and
a little more salt
would be good but it's good good job
something you can make for yourself
i would give it an eight good job proud
of you
my mom cannot help herself every time
she's walked by she's like you should do
this you should do that
next i'm going to be making mana ish
zatar i love menna izato
so i'm going to be making it for my mom
today i'mma be honest this
is pizza dough of course first we need
some flour
i feel like a child right now just a
little bit
[Music]
so i used to work at a pizza shop
actually fun fact so
let me show you all my skills this is
such a mess i
actually did not like making pizzas i'm
just gonna stick to the cash register
and do what i do best
flash a smile and take the customer's
money i'm already messing it up my mom
likes thin crust so i'm gonna try to
make this thin for her
what am i doing mamma mia
here i go again i get really paranoid
when i spray
pans and stuff so i just like douse it
but cute
clear some of this
just dropped the roller maybe i should
have mixed it beforehand but
whatever and then maizata i got
myzatar from the holy land but you can
definitely buy yours from a local
grocery store near you
oh hide loves out there so much
[Music]
somebody's parent is probably having a
heart attack watching me do this because
i do not think i'm doing this right
okay this is like really not how you're
supposed to do it but whatever
i hope it comes out good y'all
this is zatar what makes a good mana
mistake
the dough definitely the good qualities
i thought
we get ours out there from back home
it's good that those a little thicker
than what i prefer
i like it a little thinner just a little
more olive oil mixed in with this after
a little dry on top but still good i
mean i would give it a seven
did you know that's pizza though no i
did not
i'm kind of nervous for this one but
okay
for our final meal i'm going to be
making sakhan
and um is a classic palestinian chicken
dish
i actually have this memory when i was
like i think i was like nine
in palestine and my family and i went to
this restaurant on the outside of
ramallah and
i just remember there was like flowers
around the restaurant and it was vibrant
and it just was so like idyllic
and that was the first time i ever had
him sucking when i was nine years old
okay so you have to pat your chicken dry
clean it and stuff obviously
these are bone-in chicken breasts
because that's what my mom likes but
typically it's like a chicken thigh and
a chicken leg that you would use within
a
second
just a little bit so now i got to do the
spice mix
the recipe calls for a quarter teaspoon
of nutmeg we do not have ground nutmeg
so my mom said i have to grate this
myself
i've never ground nutmeg in my life then
i need a teaspoon of salt
pepper cinnamon cinnamon cinnamon
this is what's going to make it so this
is called sumac
oh my god it's so good it's like it's
kind of tarty like look at the color in
that sumac
like that's so that that is really
beautiful
oh yes
i love onions you know i was gonna do
two onions but that's a lot
i hope i don't cry at this point i'm
honestly just gonna like
eyeball it which is probably not what
you're supposed to do but
i'm just gonna do what feels right i'm
gonna put it on like a medium high
because i'm impatient but
i should have done the two onions but
whatever dang
i really burnt this like the pan is
black at the bottom my mom's gonna be so
mad at me for messing up her pan
so now i just have to put this in the
oven wait
huh oh
i have to bake the chicken on top of the
bread
what makes a good sauce the bread the
onions you need a lot of onions i should
have done the two onions i'm not an
onion person but this is the one dish
well i will eat the onions because it
needs a lot of onions and the cement
good quality so mac smells delicious it
looks really good
he did a good job of presentation i must
say usually traditionally it's made with
like leg thigh combo or you can use
cornish hens and split them open
but to me this is what i like i'm a
brushed woman
why did you say that sorry
it just goes out of my mouth see it's
cooked really nicely
it's not pink i was worried he would
undercook it but he did not
and traditionally you eat it with your
with your hands
it's actually very good one thing i will
say it's a little salty
i'm just gonna do what feels right but
in general it's actually delicious
the bread is nice and crispy the way i
like it has a crunch and it's crispy
some mac is good still too the onions
are also a little salty
i would rate it in eight but only
because of the salt
i mean taste wise in general when
chicken is cooked perfectly
bread is cooked perfectly and that would
be the only reason i would give it an
eight
just because of saltiness sucked in
[Music]
you